the first things we say in the
relationships are the things that we
believe about ourselves I'm Type A I'm
organized I'm on time or I'm kind of
messy I'm not that clean I uh tend to be
late what's crazy to me is that a lot of
people make these labels these
assertions about who they are and they
will be counter to what they're actually
trying to do it's like saying oh I'm a
lazy ass why would you ever say that
about yourself like why you're basically
training them treat me like a lazy ass
expect me to behave in a way that a lazy
ass would and then when they start
subtly speaking to you in that way it
reinforces the behavior that you have
which is ultimately not what you wanted
to begin with